i want a pair of the birkenstocks that i
wear but with laces so i was like i'll
just put them on and i wore them to
paris for fashion week and virgil saw me
wearing them and he's like yo i gotta do
it and so he put the swoosh and he said
you know put the air ortho which i
thought was pretty funny
hi my name is chris gibbs i'm the owner
of union los angeles and this is my life
and sneakers
[Music]
born and raised in canada ottawa canada
moved to new york for college in 94 met
my now wife then girlfriend who was like
you need a real job you need to like be
cooler and she eventually got me a job
working at union and that was in 96 and
i never left i'm still here i was hired
by james jebia who had started union
with his then girlfriend marianne fusco
but marianne
ran the day-to-day and pretty much
taught me everything i knew and that's
who i worked with for the most part but
that was
their story they started in 89 together
this predates supreme there's basically
like a little family tree union stucy
supreme undefeated union was opened in
89 in new york by james and marianne but
eddie kind of ran the store there eddie
moved to la in 91 and opened up the
stucy union sean stucey had established
like a really good relationship with
eddie and james through the new york
store eventually they decided to open up
stucy shops that they ran later on james
goes to open up supreme so then
obviously james who started union now
has supreme he's running stucy for sean
in new york eddie owns the la union and
is running stucy for sean here in
los angeles sneakers got so big in union
that basically eddie teamed up with
james bond who had k-bond here and
basically started undefeated as the
sneaker extension to k-bond in union and
so at some point around 2009
when the recession hit eddie and i were
talking he offered me the opportunity to
be able to take it over from him buy it
from him in essence i had already been
doing so much for the store for so long
that it was a seamless transition no one
would have known eddie to this day is
still gives me advice
on a regular basis and is still super
supportive
i suppose there's kind of two ways that
i look at
how you know fashion and sneakers and
what that all meant to me i definitely
remember like the first time i got to
make the decision of what shoe i was
going to buy for myself it was in middle
school i had to have these chuck taylors
but even as a middle schooler i was
really into color so i would never get
the black or the white i always wanted
like a weird color every 80s baby of a
certain
you know
elk eventually matriculates to like
jordan my first jordan would have been a
three so that would be the next pivot
and then getting into all those like
late 80s the jordans the nike assaults
it wasn't until i started working at
union where i think that
light switch
got turned on to like really thinking
about fashion
[Music]
it's funny because we kind of just re
told that story through the lens of our
dunk release which was you know i'm a
student i'm broke i'm living in new york
i can barely pay rent dunks at that time
were a very utilitarian shoe it ended up
becoming this uniform for like young
creatives downtown creatives because
we're all broke you know and so that was
my entry into that
it wasn't really until i went to japan
for the first time in 2001 where i saw
how japan treated the dunk where they
have the brazil's yellow and all these
crazy colors my mind exploded and i was
like oh this is insane and that's when i
really got into like
sneaker culture right there japan
was a extremely early adopter of
streetwear and so we would sell a large
majority of our product to japanese
students japanese tourists to japanese
parallel buyers today it's reselling
back then it was called parallel buy and
parallel buying the intention
was to bring something that's not
available
from another geo from another city from
another space and offer it to people who
want something different and there
wasn't a crazy markup that's why it's
called parallel buying you bought it for
a hundred maybe you made an extra 20
bucks but it was more about bringing
something new i would admit to anyone
that i run union through the lens of
that guy and his first trip to japan
talk about
your top five my top five so just pull
them out
so i got the mars yards
union here in la
when these shoes launched we launched
this shoe we did a full build out
in the store it was the shoes there was
a jacket there were some bags and we did
a full kind of execution and activation
in the store much like what happens here
all the time now but this was absolutely
the first what i like about this shoe is
i thought he did an incredible job of
taking like the sensibilities of the old
80s silhouettes but bringing it into a
modern time on a modern outer sole the
fabrics are really dope the colors are
like i can wear this shoe with anything
because the colors are kind of like
so nondescript built to harachi's
you might be surprised to see these in
but i think these have a special place
in my heart for my high school
basketball days i definitely am
into like kind of a boxy toe box
vamp and this would have been one maybe
one of the earlier exoskeleton shoes and
i really like still to this day i love
the shape i love the lines on this shoe
we've got
you know
shameless self promotion but we got my
my aj ones this has become my everyday
shoe the original design intention with
these shoes was to make them look beat
up but i didn't have the balls to go
through with it so we just ended up
doing like the antique sole and we did
the antiquing on the edge of the leather
as kind of a hint to that i'll admit i
am spoiled i have a number of pairs on
ice more than i'd like to admit there
isn't a day that has that hasn't gone by
in the last five years where someone
hasn't asked me if we still have ones
and the answer is no because we don't
and everyone some of those people are
good friends
and some of those people might even be
size 11 and
they don't know how many 11's i have for
myself
so sorry guys but uh this is my baby so
i love these
we got
my favorite my air orthos
uh rest in peace to virgil i'm a big
birkenstock guy so that's my non-sneaker
shoe that you'll see one day i went and
bought a pair these are the boston's the
black leather boston's i'm not like a
world-class customizer no one would call
me that but i like
cut the buckle off because these are
boston's here
cut the buckle off
punched lace holes in them because i was
like yo wouldn't it be dope that like i
want a pair of like the birkenstocks
that i wear which would either be the
boston or the london actually these are
boston's these are london's london's
have the but what with laces and they
make a version of it but i don't really
like it so i was like i'll just put them
on and you know this is right around
when virgil dropped his the tens and so
i was like oh i'll add the laces because
that'll make it you know whatever so i
was wearing these a lot and i wore them
to paris for fashion week and virgil saw
me wearing them and he's like yo i gotta
do it and so he put the swoosh and he
said you know put the air ortho which i
thought was pretty funny so these are
some favorites of mine obviously for
a nostalgic reason last but not least
least but not last
earlier on i said chucks were kind of my
first introduction into sneaker world
they're still my favorite a while ago
converse did a collaboration with damien
hurst and these are them and it blew my
mind i loved the fabric they used this
really crazy fabric colors were like
i always like muted colors so it wasn't
this bright red it was this kind of
orangey muted red so these are these are
them
there it is
let's go from five to top three okay i'm
gonna remove
these
and i'm gonna remove my hair orthos
let's go to top two let's let's take
third place out drop another
front of the metal where's yard
i got two kids you're gonna ask me which
to choose between my two kids wow
i guess i'll keep like the ones
why not
one a one b but i'll keep those those
have been my daily drivers since i made
them i wear them almost every day so
much so that i haven't been wearing my
chucks
[Music]
we as a store
you know the preeminent streetwear store
or would be very familiar with making
collabs carrying the collabs that
everybody makes so by the time i took
over it was you know like a easy muscle
a muscle that was
used all the time i did the 180s so we
did the clerk's pack and i think that
was 2006 and that was
fun awesome dope everything union was
one of the first adidas consortium
members we did a couple consortium shoes
we did a converse we did a vans we've
had quite a few collaborations over the
years and it's always fun and it's
always good to do it but the jordan team
i knew them because they'd come and
they'd do like inspiration shopping at
the store once a year and then one year
they were like yo can we take you for a
coffee and pick your brain and they
really were trying to figure out apparel
and i think at one point they're like
well what would you do and i was like yo
if i went to like the rose bowl and
found like some dope perfectly patinaed
vintage jordan t-shirts and sweatshirts
that's something i'd get pretty excited
about and then a couple months later a
box shows up in my office and it's a
whole bunch of like patina jordan stuff
and they're like yo like we took your
notes those are samples we want to work
with you what do you want to do like
blue skies what do you want to do and i
was like all right well i've got to tell
you one thing you can't separate the
apparel from the footwear you have to
treat them equally and if we treat them
and in doing so we need to add a
footwear to this capsule
well what should you want to do i was
like ah i want to do the one they're
like really you want to do the one
because we had a bunch of flight stuff
and they're like flight stuff's more
like the three or the four i was like
you're getting too
like nerdy on it the intention of this
design is not the year streetwear is
just like more about a feeling so i was
like the streetwear part of this is just
there's an era from 89 to 93 of just
vintage jordan stuff
and
that era has to start with the thing
that started it all the one they were
like yeah let's do it we put our all
into the launch we told the launch
through the story of the rose bowl
little thing we did and and vintage and
i had no idea
how much people were gonna come to
appreciate this shoe and go crazy for it
no idea i was blown away
so with the two i just
i got really inspired by like
utilitarian work clothing and work
uniforms where they have like labeling
and like directional you know this is
the purpose of this jacket or this shoe
and it would be written on the outside
like very like
milspec milspec does that too so i
wanted to make sure we had all the
labels all over the shoe and then i kind
of liked the idea of like
bringing some exo ideas so we kind of
made this area a little bit more
industrial looking i've probably
designed from a very familiar place and
what's familiar to me is my late 80s
introduction to sneaker culture do i
want to lean into that do i want to
bring it up modern do i want to make it
a little bit more sophisticated and make
it more like fashion and so i think with
this one i wanted to make it fashion
street wear is very alive i'll say that
streetwear is not
a
silo of fashion that is juxtaposed
against other silos streetwear can be
contemporary
it can be
high fashion it can be luxury it can
live in all of them i think high fashion
they're not dumb they're like oh that's
what everybody wants like gen
x y and z are the ones spending money on
fashion not boomers anymore so we have
to make stuff that they're going to
appreciate so we have to speak in their
language and their language is
streetwear right now and so they've
smartly started to make a lot of their
collections through a streetwear veneer
how do you think sneakers plays into
this whole construct of fashion and
streetwear
what do you see for the future
this is probably a weird way to answer
it but i think a lot about like south
park and they had a couple episodes a
couple years ago where they were
suggesting is that like america's
trapped in this cycle of remembering and
the things that they were familiar to
growing up with
disney is maybe taking wild advantage of
that right now and it's just star wars
up just and it's bubba fett and if you
you know and then it's the stormtrooper
and then it's they're tapping into this
thing that is some for some reason i
don't know i'm not a
sociologist or a psychologist but it
seems to be this special moment in time
for a lot of people right and so
sneakers is that for a guy of a certain
age my age i'm gen x right so sneakers
hits this chord for a gen x kid i think
gen y and gen z although they have their
own take on it and they're definitely
doing their own thing they've taken a
lot of cues from gen x and so
sneakers is just this really special
thing they are the accoutrement to
your fashion they're the finishing piece
they're the cherry on top of every
outfit and so much so that you think
about the cherry before you think about
the outfit which is kind of crazy
yeah thank you
[Music]